ce qui apparaît c'est que l'auteur
présumé qui a été présenté hier devant
un magistrat instructeur apparaît comme
étant celui qui a donné un coup de
couteau fatal à un individu qui était
lui-même porteur d'une arme à feu et qui
en avaient fait usage usage juste avant
la deuxième chose que j'observe c'est
que pour deux des trois homicides que
nous avons à déplorer depuis le début de
l'année nous avons affaire à des
personnes qui était porteur d'une arme à
feu et qui ont été elle-même victime
ensuite de ces homicides volontaires
la conclusion c'est quoi c'est de dire
que lorsqu'on nous dit on ce munis
d'armes à feu pour se protéger on se
trompe totalement